ok today we're going to learn about
non-renewable energy we're gonna learn
about the two main types of
non-renewable energy we're gonna see how
they work and then we're gonna learn
about the advantages and the
disadvantages okay so first of all it's
important we understand what is meant by
non-renewable energy a non-renewable
energy source is one that is not being
replenished as it's being used so
eventually it will run out when all the
reserves have been used up we can't use
it again and again so the first type
we're going to learn about are fossil
fuels
now fossil fuels there are their three
main types of fossil fuel we need to
know they are coal oil and natural gas
now all of these different types of
fossil fuels take millions of years to
form underneath the ground and they need
to be extracted from the ground through
mining
in order to get hold of these resources
now what we're going to look at is just
how one of them we're going to use coal
as an example of how we can actually
generate electricity from coal so the
first thing you do is you need to dig up
the coal and then it's crushed into dust
so then the coal is burnt releasing lots
and lots of energy that energy can then
be used to do the following thing it can
be used to heat up lots of water which
is in a massive boiler now when the
water gets hot enough it turns to steam
and it rises and it's forced under high
pressure it turns this structure here
called a turbine a little bit like the
wind turbines you often find in fields
that also generate electricity so this
part here is the boiler now the turbine
is connected to a structure called a
generator and within the generator this
is where the electricity is is is
generated is made there's an actual
there's another video to show this
process in more
tale of exactly how electricity is is
great or generated within the generator
okay so it's kind of similar for oil or
natural gas again it's just burning one
of them to make water turn to steam to
turn a turbine to power a generator okay
now the advantages of fossil fuels it's
first of all they are really reliable
they're a reliable source currently to
produce a lot of electricity to to give
electricity for everyone across across
the nation the other good thing about
them is they can be used to meet energy
demand so if there's a sudden demand for
more energy we can just burn more of the
fossil fuels in order to produce more
energy they also compared to lots of
other types of of energy generation
they're comparatively cheap to build and
to run so those are the benefits of
fossil fuels now there are lots and lots
of of negative of disadvantages of
fossil fuels as well because when you
burn the fossil fuels you're releasing
lots of harmful gases one is carbon
dioxide that could lead to global
warming there's another video to talk
that talks more about this particular
pollutant as well as this pollutant not
carbon dioxide but sulfur dioxide which
can cause acid rain again there's
another video it talks about these
effects in much more detail also if
you're using oil there could be oil
spillages which can be extremely
detrimental to animals such as bird such
as Birds so you can be completely
covered with the oil and can lead to the
deaths of of lots and lots of wildlife
and the other big negative thing about
fossil fuels is they will one day run
out because they are non-renewable they
cannot be replenished as we go so those
that's basically an overview of fossil
fuels now the other type of
non-renewable energy source is nuclear
power so instead of using fossil fuels
we have these different these different
fuels called uranium or plutonium again
are non-renewable because once you've
used them they are they're gone we can't
replenish them so the way that these
work is basically we have large unstable
nuclei and when we fire neutrons at them
it causes the nuclei to split into
smaller daughter daughter nuclei and
also it releases lots and lots of energy
so this energy released from splitting
these uranium or plutonium nuclei can
then be used in a very similar way to
fossil fuels to heat up water in a
boiler to then turn a turbine to
generate electricity in a generator so
what are the advantages of nuclear power
now compared to fossil fuels they really
produce low levels of co2 because unlike
burning the fossil fuels splitting these
atoms these nuclei does not release lots
of carbon dioxide also they can produce
a large amount of electricity so a
relatively small massive of these of
these substances uranium or plutonium
releases a lot of energy now the really
negative sides about nuclear power is
first of all it's extremely expensive to
build a nuclear power plant and to
decommission one after it's been built
but probably the biggest problem with
nuclear energy is it produces nuclear
waste
now nuclear waste is extremely harmful
to people and it stays dangerous for
thousands of years so a big problem is
thinking what to actually do with this
nuclear waste once it's been created
so that guys is basically an overview of
non-renewable energy thank you